Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P. I've talked about
people canceling memberships. Here's someone who's
so furious about our recent guest hosts that he's
signing up for memberships merely
to cancel them. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hello, this is Alan from New Jersey.
I'm calling to speak to Pat because Pat just
claims that Billy did a good jobs substitute
hosting the show. Yeah, he really did not do
a good job. You did a terrible job. And I need to
cancel my membership and then cancel it a second
time. That's how disappointed I am. Move Beasley
is. I can't cancel once I have to cancel my
membership, then sign up again and then cancel the
second time. Right. Show how disappointed I am.
And Luke Beasley, he's horrible. Is Pat or Farron
Cousins are No. One. Wow. The only two options,
Pat. They're cousins or no one.
Speaker 1: Wow. Very, very strong. Now, obviously,
he's kidding about signing up just to cancel
memberships. Extremely strong feelings about our
guest hosts. Every guest hosts got rave reviews
and terrible reviews. So we're we're not picking
on Luke Beasley here at all. There were people
who wrote to me and said Luke was fantastic,
but I can't stand Baron's facial hair and I didn't
like Pat's delivery. There were people who wrote
in and said, Pat's great. He knows the flow of the
show. Everybody else is bad. There were others who
wrote in and said, The only guy ready for prime
time is Farren, Pat and Luke. Don't know what
they're doing. Listen, hopefully there was a
little bit of something for everybody. That's
the hope. We have a fantastic bonus show for you
today. Stacks of bodies found dead in a trailer.
A horrifying story. We will we will talk about
it. Elizabeth Warren says Democrats are two
votes away from codifying Roe v Wade, but is it
too late? And a study finds that cannabis users
are 25% more likely to need emergency care
or hospitalization. But is it because of the
cannabis I know I mentioned these were yesterday's
stories. Yesterday's bonus show was canceled.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money and everybody
else that makes money to fund themselves as bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Because of yesterday's emergency
house committee hearing, the bonus show was
canceled. So we will do those stories today
sign up for the bonus show at joined Pacman dot
com you can use the coupon code indict that's I
and I t indict you all know what it means.
Everybody knows what that means right now.
Sign up at join pacman dot com. I'll see you on
the bonus show or otherwise back here tomorrow.